VIJAY MENON: Thanks
for coming.
We're talking about Putting the
App Back Into Web App--
Web Programming With Dart.
How many of you just attended
the last talk by Lars and
Kasper on Dart?
Great.
I think that was most of you.
If you haven't, you should
be able to pick it up.
Dart's a very familiar
language.
We're excited about the Dart
programming language for its
potential for creating web apps,
particularly apps code
that runs in the browser.
I'm Vijay Menon.
DAN GROVE: And I'm Dan Grove.
We're here from Google's
Seattle Team.
So how many of you have
used web apps before?
It looks something like this.
All right.
How many of you are
happy with this?
Beautiful.
I had to ask.
VIJAY MENON: This talk
is not for you.
Sorry.
DAN GROVE: When I got to Google
back in late 2007,
there was a lot of talk about
developing [INAUDIBLE].
But they're really ugly.
But that's OK because they
all [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Your mic's
not working.
VIJAY MENON: Oh, your
mic is off.
DAN GROVE: It says it's on.
I'll try it again.
Let's see.
VIJAY MENON: You got it?
DAN GROVE: It's not working.
How about now?
No?
VIJAY MENON: Why don't I take
over for a little bit while we
get Dan miced up properly.
So yeah, now it's 2012, and our
expectations have changed.
And one big thing that's changed
in the past five
years-- you've seen it here at
Google I/O. We have these
things now like tablets
and mobile devices.
And that's really changed
our expectations of
what a nice app is.
And this is an app that we wrote
to specifically run well
on a tablet.
And we had quite a few
aims with this.
One is that we wanted to
make it beautiful.
And to do that, we really wanted
precise control over
how the app looked on the screen
and on a variety of
different form factors.
We wanted it to be very nice to
interact with, particularly
with the latest and
greatest devices.
Touch.
We wanted rich animation.
So we want the illusion
of infinite scroll.
We want 60 frames per
second interaction.
We just want this thing to be
able to respond to us very
quickly in, again, a variety
of form factors.
So what we were interested in
figuring out is whether we
could build this sort of
an app in the browser.
So basically our experiences
were validated.
And this is the same exact app
running on Chrome with pretty
much the same sort of interface
capabilities and
interactivity with it.
DAN GROVE: Yeah, so users
really wanted to have
something that was a lot better
than what we were
giving them back in 2007.
And when we designed Swarm, we
really wanted to make this
thing beautiful.
And we think that the mobile
space really has driven the
beauty requirements
for apps quite a
long way at this point.
We also wanted the app
to be really fast.
We wanted it to start
up instantly.
And we also wanted
it to be super
responsive to user actions.
And there are a bunch of
good reasons for that.
One of them is how many of you
guys have had Wi-Fi problems
here today?
Anyone?
So that sucks, right?
You're trying to use
your application.
You're waiting for the
web to respond.
It's terrible.
We were told this morning that
no Wi-Fi was working at all
for speaker talks.
And so we were happy that our
app actually works offline.
So that was great.
We really wanted an app
that works offline.
But we also wanted one that
would leverage the cloud when
the cloud was available.
VIJAY MENON: Yeah,
Lars and Kasper
talked about this theme.
It's been hit a few times.
One of the reasons we did it,
the news app as our test
application in Dart, well
one, we're news junkies.
And we knew it was an app we'd
use, which is always good.
But the other is that, that
was a fairly common
experience.
With the web, you don't
have to install.
Probably, most of you've
gotten this experience,
particularly on a mobile device,
where you get a link
to a news story, you click on
it, and then you get this
message that says, please
install this app for
such-and-such newspaper you've
never heard of to get the best
viewing experience.
And there's many cases
where it makes
sense to install apps.
But that's one where at
least we think it
made no sense at all.
We just want the system to get
out of our way and be able to
just get to our content in
the browser on the web.
DAN GROVE: Yeah, so we wanted
to build a web application
that was really first
class in every way.
The good thing was that the web
had actually changed a ton
in the last five years.
So one thing that's happened is
that web capabilities have
improved radically.
So you've gotten things
like animation
and Canvas and WebGL.
I'll tell you a story.
I was incredibly disappointed
when I first arrived at Google
back coming up on
five years ago.
Because I thought, the web can
do all this cool stuff.
There's all this great stuff.
And I went out, and I met with
a bunch of teams to find out
what they're doing.
They said, well Web 2.0, it's
string concatenation,
essentially.
That was basically it.
There was nothing more
to it than that.
And we've moved way past that.
You can actually do these kinds
of cool animations and
3D graphics on the web,
which is fantastic.
We've also gotten rid of
a lot of plug-ins.
So you can actually build audio
that competes with the
best native audio.
You don't need plug-ins
for video.
That's another fantastic
thing.
And then there are really crazy
things that have been
developed, like sockets.
You could actually have a socket
between the client and
the server.
I mean, it's 2012.
It's about time, but you
can actually do it.
One nice thing I'd point out
here is that this is code for
creating a web socket in Dart,
and it's actually very pretty.
It's actually typed.
It's very easy to
reason about it.
It has nice closures.
When I first put up the
code for this--
I actually put up the
JavaScript code for
WebSockets--
and frankly, it was a lot uglier
than the Dart code.
So we'll be talking a
lot more about this.
But I think it's really
fantastic.
And there are a lot of other
really cool features that are
coming on the web.
And there are more coming
all the time.
There are all kinds of talks
here about doing new P2P
real-time video and audio and
all kinds of other neat stuff.
VIJAY MENON: The other axis, big
axis, that's changed over
time is JavaScript
performance.
And this is a really
interesting graph.
Because for a very, very long
period of time, up to 2007,
performance of code running
in the browser
didn't really change.
And then in 2008, something
happened.
One of those things, at least,
was that Chrome was released
with V8, its JavaScript
engine.
And performance suddenly
got a lot better.
And then over the past five
years, it's really gotten
much, much better, not
just on Chrome but on
other browsers as well.
In fact, even your mobile
devices today run JavaScript
far faster than what a desktop
did five years ago.
And what's interesting about
this is that a lot of the apps
that we interact with were
designed in this old world,
where you really had no ability
to do any interesting
compute on the browser itself.
It was just way too slow.
And this is going to be kind of
a running theme here that
we'll get to later, that we
can rethink apps today.
This is not Moore's Law.
This is Moore's Law on steroids
if you look at the
gains that we've seen
in performance
in just five years.
And that lets us dramatically
rethink how we design apps.
DAN GROVE: Right.
So the bottom line here is that
the browser has really
changed across two axes.
It's gotten far more
capabilities, and the
performance has increased so
much that we can start doing
things radically differently
from the way we were doing
them in the past.
So we talked about the web.
But why are we here talking
about Dart?
Well, programs don't just
get better magically.
They get better because
programmers develop them.
And developing these better
apps often requires bigger
apps that are made out
of building blocks.
And that requires actually
programming at scale.
And when we talk about
programming in scale on Dart,
we're talking about things
like 100,000-line or a
million-line application.
You're unlikely to build
that yourself.
In fact, you're unlikely to
have two or three people
building that in
a small group.
What you're likely to
have are actual
composable building blocks.
You're going to need
to reuse code.
And we're not talking about
copying and pasting code or
downloading a little
piece of JavaScript
and pasting it together.
We're talking about something
where you actually want to be
able to build libraries and
reuse those libraries.
In order to do that, you
actually want structure.
So structure is great, because
it actually lets you start
reasoning about your
application.
All those things you learned
back in Computer Science 101
are actually very relevant
in Dart.
You have classes, and you have
interface, and you have all
these nice things.
You also want to have
static checking.
So grep works great when you
have 1,000 lines of code or
something like that.
Grep doesn't work great
when you have a
million lines of code.
And at Google, we actually have
a number of people who
spend their time thinking about
tools to go and search
over your code and reason
about your code.
Static checking and static
checkability of a language
really assist this.
You also want it
to be toolable.
vi or TextMate probably start
breaking down when your
application gets to
be 100,000 lines.
You actually want to be able
to jump to definition.
You want to be able to find out
if a type exists, or you
want to be able to find out
if a method exists.
All these things are really
important, and one of the
things we'll be talking about
in this talk is the Dart
Editor and how it helps
you with these things.
So we have a bunch of tools to
make Dart easier to program.
And the first of these
is the Dart Editor.
This is an Eclipse-based editor
that Kasper showed off
in the last talk.
And it provides a lot of very
nice features, which Vijay
will be popping into
in a minute.
We also have something
that we call Dartium.
And Dartium is our own
home-brewed version of
Chromium with the Dart
VM embedded in it.
And this is really fantastic
because it gives you that
instant edit refresh cycle
that everyone likes.
When it's time to actually
deploy your app, Kasper talked
at length about the Dart2JS
Compiler in the last talk.
The goal here is that Dart
does not break the web.
We compiled Dart to the tip of
all the major browsers that
are auto updated.
And we also compile
it to run on IE9+.
VIJAY MENON: So rather than
just tell you about this,
let's dive in and show.
And one of things we're going to
show later in this talk is
we're going to go into detail
on the Swarm newsreader.
But before I dive into that,
let's start with something
really simple.
Let's just go into the Dart
Editor here and create a new
application.
Let's just create a "Hello
World!" application here.
So it's a nice wizard to just
get me bootstrapped.
But it's really quite
simple here.
There's just--
If you look at what this
created, I have an HTML file.
Let's go there first.
That's, of course,
where you land.
And it's HTML.
The things I really want to call
out to you here are some
things that we've done to help
you debug your application on
Dartium and also deploy
it on any browser with
the same HTML file.
So first you'll notice two
script tags at the bottom.
The first one has a type you
may not have seen before,
application slash dart.
That's a new type that is
intended for browsers that
support Dart natively.
And in our case,
that's Dartium.
And so Dartium will be able to
just run hello.dart directly
with no tools involved.
You just change your
app, reload it in
Dartium, and it works.
Of course, you want your app
to run on all browsers.
And to make that easy, at least
for the development
perspective, we have this little
script called dart.js,
which just bootstraps.
It detects if you've got
Dart loaded or not--
or Dart supported
natively or not.
And if you don't have Dart
supported natively, it will
replace it with a JS version
instead that you've generated.
And of course, if you're
deploying this, you don't
necessarily want to do this
stuff, you could just deploy
directly with the JavaScript
that you generate
out of Dart to JS.
So let's take a look
at hello.dart.
We're importing a library.
I'll get to that in a moment.
The main entry point of any
Dart application is Main.
And it's calling a method called
showMessage here, which
is taking a string and doing an
operation on it to show the
message "Welcome to Dart"
on a web page.
So let's just fire that up.
This is running in Dartium.
And you can see it's just
loaded up right here.
So let's take a look at this.
So first of all, dart:HTML is
the way you interact with the
browser at the lowest
level in Dart.
And we had a few things that we
were trying to do when we
created this library.
First, we wanted to basically
give you all the capabilities
that you have in JavaScript for
interacting with the DOM.
So anything you can pretty much
do in JavaScript you can
do in Dart as well.
But we also wanted to take
the opportunity to
clean up the API.
A lot of times, people will use
frameworks, like jQuery,
for example, just because the
raw DOM API is kind of clumsy
to use and shows its age.
So we definitely took
inspiration from some of these
frameworks and tried to just
clean up the raw DOM.
So just accessing the DOM
directly was nice.
And then finally, this library
was really codesigned as the
Dart language itself evolved.
And we tried to make the API
take advantage of all the
features of Dart.
So for example, this query API
here is-- it's kind of
analogous to the dollar-sign
operation in jQuery if you're
used to that.
It's basically a querySelector
on the DOM looking for an
element of ID text and
then setting its Text
field to the message.
And the nice thing about this
is that it's typed.
So let's take a look at this.
So suppose we just want to
go to the declaration.
We've got the tooling to
go ahead and do that.
So we can just see, what
is this query method?
Well, we have this comment here
that tells us that it's
returns the first element in
some traversal of the document
given a string.
What is an element?
Well, we can do that too.
Just chase that down, and we
see it's an interface.
This ends up actually being one
of the basic interfaces in
the HTML DOM that we can
go ahead and work with.
So a nice thing also about using
the Dart Editor is that
it's doing some analysis here.
So it knows the type.
So remember, query returns
an element.
And so you're able to use that
information and get auto
completion here.
And we know what
the fields are.
And so, as a programmer,
you can quickly search.
You don't have to look
up documentation.
You have at your fingertips
what you can do.
Another nice thing is if
you do make typos,
the editor can tell.
It'll look at the type
information, and show you that
you did something wrong.
DAN GROVE: There's a red
line under there, for
those in the back.
VIJAY MENON: The yellow line or
problem, and if we look at
the list of problems
here, we see, hey,
there's something wrong.
Text is not a member
of element.
If you were at the last talk,
one of the things that Kasper
talked about in terms of
JavaScript is that it had this
just trucking mentality.
And this is a case where, if
you do this kind of code in
JavaScript and you misspell
the field, it will happily
just create a new property
called txt on your element.
And it won't show up.
And you'll just be wondering
what happened.
And you'll have to dig
that out yourself.
Here, we get that information
right away.
And that's, again, the
philosophy of early error
information in Dart, which we
think is going to be very
important as we go
to larger apps.
So let's show more about Dart
HTML before we move on.
One of the fundamental things
you want to do with DOM is
create elements.
And we have a nice way
of doing that.
In JavaScript you
need a factory.
In Dart you just call
a constructor.
So we can call new
CanvasElement
to create the Canvas.
And the constructor for Canvas
takes height and width.
It uses a feature called
Optional Named Parameters.
So I don't have to remember
the order in which it's--
whether it's height or width.
I can just go ahead
and invoke that.
And this typo, at least,
was on purpose.
It shows that, hey,
I got it wrong.
That was the wrong name
of the field.
Every time I give this talk
I have different typos.
So you can guess which ones--
They're all on purpose.
It's all right.
So yeah, I could tell right away
that there's a problem.
And I can go ahead
and fix that.
And again, I get cool type
completion from here.
So again, I know what's
on the Canvas.
I know that it's got a context,
a 2D context, in
particular.
Usually want to get at the
context to be able to do
interesting things.
And then if I want to set the
fill style in the context, not
the Context 2D, again, I
can see what's there.
Let's make this one red.
Let's also fill a rectangle.
Go with something very
simple here.
But again, I see, as I'm typing
in, what the signature
of this method is.
So I don't have to really guess
at what the parameters
are or have to look up
things on the side.
It just sort of works for me.
And let's go ahead and add this
to the document and see
how that looks.
So I'm just going to get the
nodes of the document's body.
And I'm going to go ahead
and add the Canvas.
And let's load that
up in Dartium.
And now you can see our "hello"
app with just a little
Canvas at the bottom.
All right.
So let's make this a little
bit more interesting.
First of all let's just--
Because I don't type too fast,
let me just do some cut and
paste and create a second
Canvas here,
and save this off.
And as I do this, one nice thing
I get is, hey there's
some errors.
You can't just do it
the way you did.
The editor shows me right away
that Canvas and context are
duplicate definitions.
And in this case, I can look at
my code and know that these
two definitions don't conflict
with each other.
And I can make sure that I'm
doing the right thing here.
And let's make this one a little
bit different for fun.
Give it a different width.
Let's make it blue, and
just load it back up.
And again, I'm just
reloading--
I'm restarting the browser,
because it's so fast.
But you don't have to do that.
I can just go change it here.
I do have to save my file.
But then I can just go
back into Dartium
here and reload it.
And everything just works.
So that's how you
create elements.
You've got nice constructors
in Dart that you
can use to do it.
You've got named optional
parameters to make it easy to
set things up.
Let's say you want a query.
That's a fundamental
operation.
And we showed one example
right here where we're
querying for text, for the
element with the text ID.
Let's do another one where we
get a list of all of the
Canvas objects.
So Query All is another
operation like query, but this
returns a list.
So now you get nice typing
information.
List is a fundamental data
structure in Dart.
And there's nice language
support for it.
So I get this list, and it's
really easy to just iterate
over all the elements
in the list.
So this will give me each
Canvas, and I can do something
interesting with it.
So in this case, let's go ahead
and set the context.
And note that this
is pretty cool.
The editor is still able to
reason about this and do some
nice auto complete for me.
So let's fill in another
rectangle, slightly different,
so we can actually
see something.
So this should go through the
two Canvases on my page and
draw an existing rectangle.
So let's see if I
did this right.
And yes, you can see that
here is the second
rectangle on both.
Iterating over properties,
this is kind of a
cool, subtle thing.
You can write this code
in JavaScript and
iterate over the list.
But it doesn't do exactly
what you want.
It will not only give you the
Canvas objects, it will also
give you the length property
and so on.
So it's not as nicely integrated
as it is in Dart.
And that makes for a pretty
cool experience.
One of the things we liked
a lot about jQuery is the
ability to chain things
together.
And you can do that in pretty
cool ways in Dart, too.
So let's do another operation
on the Canvas here.
And again, this is going
to give me a
list of all the Canvases.
And the list object in Dart has
a lot of nice functional
style methods.
So one of the things we
can do is filter.
And that takes a closure.
So we can basically say, well
let's get all of the elements
where the width is
equal to 100.
So that should give me
the second Canvas.
A lot of times--
And again, I get the nice
auto complete as I go.
A lot of times, again, when
you're working with a Canvas,
you really just want to
work with its context.
So we can go ahead and pull
out the context 2D.
So now instead of a list of
Canvas elements, we have a
list of Canvas rendering
context 2D.
That's a bit of a mouthful, but
we haven't actually had to
type that in.
So it's not so bad.
And then finally, once we have
that context that we want,
let's go ahead and, since I'm
having so much fun with
rectangles, fill another
rectangle this time.
And let's make this kind of
long, just so it shows up.
And I need to close that off.
Oh, don't have a semicolon
there.
It's awfully nice having an
editor that tells you what you
did wrong when you're giving
a live demo, by the way.
So yeah.
I save that.
Let me go ahead and
load that up.
If I did this right, yes, you
see a difference only on the
second Canvas.
So again, you've got this nice
way of just chaining things
together in Dart that you just
get for free, because we're
able to leverage the core
Dart data structures.
And one final thing I want
to get to in dart:HTML.
Fundamental thing with UIs, of
course, and web UIs, is you
want to be able to
add listeners.
So you can do that.
And that's another thing that
we've changed a bit.
Let me just go ahead and use
this text element here.
This is an element.
We can listen to all of the
events on it by just looking
at this On field, which gives us
a list of all the things we
can listen on to.
So we can easily see
what's there.
And of course, one of the more
interesting ones is click.
We can go ahead and add
our own handler that
listens to an event.
And in this case, we're
not going to do
anything with that event.
We're just going to show
a new message.
And if I did this right,
I have the event here.
OK.
So that's all running
in Dartium.
Of course, you're going to want
to be able to run your
stuff as JavaScript, and
that's easy to do.
You can just generate
JavaScript here.
And let's go there, grab that
same URL, go to another
browser, Firefox--
we haven't actually put
the Dart VM in there.
And OK.
Thank you.
Hey, it's great having an
audience that knows
what I should do.
So Firefox running.
Thank you very much.
And here's the same code.
And glad you're paying attention
and helping me out.
And it's running the same
as it ran in Chrome.
So all this tooling really
helps us out, we believe.
But you don't have to use the
tooling if you don't want to.
All of the stuff is available
there to use
at the command line.
DAN GROVE: Yeah, exactly.
So we certainly have people on
our team that will never use
an IDE ever.
And they're actually perfectly
happy writing Dart code.
These are the same people,
they use vi.
They're really addicted to it.
They're not going to switch.
But all the tools
work fine there.
So you can run the Dart VM
on the command line.
You can run the Dart Compiler
on the command line, produce
your JavaScript for your
web application.
You can use Dartium.
You can use everything.
So you don't have to buy into
all of the tools in order to
make this work.
So let's get back to Swarm and
talk about the design choices
we made and how we
think modern apps
should be built in Dart.
So going back to the goals here,
we really wanted Swarm
to be a great news reader that
was written in Dart.
Why written in Dart?
Because we care a ton about
Dart, and we actually wanted
to learn about the language.
And we wanted to iterate on
the language with a real
application.
Speed is critical.
If you work on the Dart Team,
you have to care about speed.
There's just no way around it.
So 60 frames per second is the
requirement these days.
We needed an application that
could be customized to
different form factors.
I remember the first time
we showed it to someone.
The first question we got was,
so if you want to run this on
a phone, do you have to
rewrite the entire
application?
And the answer is no.
We tried to design it in such
a way that we could actually
build customized UIs relatively
straightforwardly.
And finally, we wanted it
to be offline capable.
And not just so that the demo
would work when we were
talking at Google I/O.
But there are a
lot of other reasons.
Most of you, I guess all of us,
will wind up with these
Wi-Fi-enabled tablets that
have no connectivity when
they're outside a Wi-Fi zone or
when they're at Google I/O.
So people that have those are
going to care a ton about
being offline.
People that live in the US care
a lot about this too.
Because the mobile networks here
are pretty lousy, and you
often wind up without
connectivity.
So we needed to meet all these
goals to make Swarm work well.
So we started with the UI.
And we wanted to build
a great layout.
And we wanted to build a system
that would work nicely
on phones, on tablets,
and on the desktop.
We really liked what we saw
when we went out and
looked at CS's grid.
We thought, that's super cool.
Unfortunately, it's
not everywhere we
needed it to be yet.
It's critical to us that we not
break the web and that we
actually build Dart applications
that work across
all the browsers that
we're targeting.
We also looked at CS's
flex box, which is
also kind of cool.
But it has some problems.
One is that it doesn't
support animation.
And animation is really critical
if we're going to
build really great apps.
It's also not identical
cross browser.
And we didn't really
want to do a lot of
tweaking across browsers.
And then we had a revelation.
We thought about building this
and doing layout in code.
And that's kind of nice.
Because layout in code could
be the same everywhere.
And you can actually get
animations that work.
And we can build on all this
awesome VM speed that has been
developed over the
last five years.
We don't have to rely on only
the browser primitives.
We can actually do interesting
stuff in code.
And that was what we decided
to do for the
layout engine here.
Underneath the layout, we
thought that we would actually
try to take a fairly structured
approach to
building the application.
And it's kind of a mouthful,
like the
Model-View-ViewModel Approach.
And this has been an approach
that's been taken, basically,
since the mid-2000s for rich
client applications.
And the general idea here
is that you have Views.
And each of those Views is
coupled to its own ViewModel.
And the ViewModel essentially
maintains state that is
related to the View but that
isn't the same as the true
model that stores the data.
So ViewModels often have
transient state.
They often interact
with each other.
And they essentially mediate
between the core data model
and the UI.
Underneath the data layer,
we can actually
connect to the cloud.
And the nice thing is, if we
build our application this
way, we can actually deal with
lack of connectivity to the
cloud, which is important.
So let's walk through Swarm
and take a look at these
different parts.
So first of all, the model.
The model is the true
application state, and by that
I mean that all of the data
that we need to be able to
build the application
lives in the model.
One of the important things for
us is that, in order to
have things like offline and
local acceleration where
you're actually responding to
results on the client, you
actually need to be
able to construct
the UI on the client.
And we can do that, because we
have these powerful VMs now.
There are a lot of other neat
things that you can get if you
actually build a model
correctly.
One is tab consistency.
This is something that annoys me
constantly as I have Gmail
open on a couple of
different tabs.
And one tab says I have 20,000
unread messages, and the other
one says I have 20,001
unread messages.
It's really irritating.
We can actually use things like
shared workers on the web
to have a shared model between
different tabs and start
getting tabs that are
actually consistent.
And when that day comes, it
will be a fantastic thing.
We can also get strong data
and View separation.
And that's really nice, because
then we can actually
build different Views and
different UIs without
rebuilding the entire
application.
So let's look at what the pieces
of the Swarm model are.
So first of all, we
have the sections.
And these are the sections of
news that I've decided to
subscribe to.
So no surprise, Google is one of
them, Geek is one of them,
all the usual things.
And then we have feeds.
And the feeds are essentially
RSS feeds that
are stored per section.
And then in the model, we
have articles per feed.
And these articles are
not what you're
seeing on the screen.
These articles are the actual
full text of the articles.
We'll turn that into
UI in a little bit.
But the entire content of the
article is stored here.
Once we have the model, we can
pop up the stack a little bit
into the ViewModel.
And the ViewModel is essentially
responsible for
transforming the model
for the View.
It also performs all the
interactions between the View
and the actual application.
You can think of the View as
really being the UI side of
things and the ViewModel being
where those UI events get
modeled into something that
deals with the rest of the
application.
You can also have Events here.
You might have data that's
changing on the cloud and
popping up through the model, or
changing in some other tab
and then popping up
through the model.
All these things happen
in the ViewModel.
And we build one ViewModel for
each View in the system.
There's also a lot of
transient state
that's stored here.
For instance, in the Swarm
ViewModel, you'd have things
like the Current Section.
And you can see if you're really
close, that there's a
little carrot up underneath
the top.
And you can see the top is
actually written in red.
Current Feed so that you know
what feeds you should be
displaying on the screen.
The Current Article so that you
know where in the where in
the list your cursor is, and
then the Article Tiles.
And the Article Tiles are
things like the title, a
thumbnail for the article, an
abstract for the article, that
sort of thing.
And then, as we rise up the
stack, it's time to get into
the View itself.
And we think of Views as being
composable UI units that are
responsible for handling
all UI interaction.
We build these out of Dart
and HTML and CSS.
We looked at a number of other
options, but in the end, HTML
and CSS are actually a really
good story for the web.
If you need to, you can always
build a Custom View that
decides to render itself in
WebGL or Canvas, but we expect
that most Views will actually
get rendered with HTML.
Views are actual Dart objects.
So this is fantastic, because
you can start doing things
like deriving them
from each other.
So you can build a menu, and
then you could build a
specialized kind of menu and
actually take advantage of the
object-oriented nature
of Dart.
Views are also responsible
for handling events.
And they're responsible for
handling events that come in,
in two directions.
One is they need to handle
UI events that are
coming in from the users.
These might be clicks, or
scrolls, or keyboard events.
The View is also responsible
for handling events that
bubble up from the ViewModels.
So these could be events that
come in from another View and
get mediated through
ViewModels.
Or they could be data that's
changing out in the cloud and
gets pushed up to
the application.
So let's go take a look at
Swarm in the Editor.
VIJAY MENON: So yeah, let's do
a deep dive on Swarm now.
And this is a much bigger
application.
So let's also come at this from
the mindset that we're
actually trying to tackle
here, which is large
applications in a production
environment.
Imagine you are a new team
member on a team that's
writing Swarm.
And you're looking at this
code for the first time.
Can you just jump in
and be productive?
That's the thing that we're
trying to measure.
So let's take a look at Swarm
and find, basically, the main
HTML page here.
It looks a lot like "hello." If
we look down at the bottom,
it's a bit more complicated,
obviously.
But we, again, see the
application Dart, with
swarm.dart, the main
entry point.
And also, this Dart to
JS that will let us
boot-strap and test out.
We have this nice application
View.
So instead of looking at a long
laundry list, you can
actually see the different
libraries that we used to
compose together and
create Swarm.
So we have this entry point.
We've actually put most of the
application itself in a
separate library that we import,
create a new Swarm app
instance, and run.
And you don't have to
go searching for
this again using grep.
You can just dive in and see
what's going on here.
So this gets us to
the Swarm app.
We can take a look at that.
This is the Swarm class.
And the main elements that Dan
talked about are here.
Sections is, essentially, the
model, the data model.
FrontView is the
top-level View.
We'll get to that in a moment.
And Swarm state corresponds
to the ViewModel or the
transient UI state.
Let's take a look at what this
constructor's doing.
The first thing it's doing
is initializing from URL.
Let's take a look at
what that does.
We can just dive in here.
And we can see that,
OK, there's--
Again, you can notice
to-dos here.
This is, again, an app.
You're just diving into any
production app, it's probably
going to have some
to-dos in it.
It's always evolving, right?
And you want to find
out, which path is
this thing going on.
Well, again, we want
to be able to
just set a break point.
So let's run this, and we can
see right away that, hey, it
went down this path.
So we've got an idea, at least
in this mode, of which way
it's going.
So we can follow
the execution.
And let's go ahead and run
that to completion.
And we can see--
Oh, this is running in Chrome.
Let's get the version
here in Dartium.
And you can see that here's the
app running in Dartium.
And if you are used to Chrome
Developer Tools, you can just
load that up as well.
And you can see that all of that
is actually starting to
get pretty nicely integrated,
as well, in Dartium.
So just as a quick thing, let's
just try loading this
application and seeing what's
actually coming across.
And this is all being served
from the local file
system, in this case.
One thing you'll notice
is that there's
lots of Dart files.
If you include transitively all
the libraries that we're
pulling through together
here, there's about
60-some Dart files.
So as you're just editing and
debugging, this is great.
Because I just change one of
those files, I reload, and I
get the new effect right here.
And of course, as you compile
this to JavaScript, it's going
to do the smart thing and
create one or very few
JavaScript files that
you deploy.
And when you eventually deploy,
Dart will do similar
things there as well.
So now you've kind of gotten
familiar with the app.
Let's suppose you have
an initial task.
And the task we have is, as you
dive into a news article,
we want to show the author
as well as the feed name.
So let's say that we want to go
ahead and make that change.
All right.
Let's go back to Swarm.
We saw where the top-level
View is.
We can go in and dive
into there.
The top-level View is
essentially a compositional
set of Views.
So if we look at the different
pieces in this class, we can
see here's a topView, the
headerView, the sliderMenu
Menu that goes across the top.
And again, a lot of other
different names of Views.
If we just click on something,
we can kind of get a sense of
what's what by it, because the
comments just show up at--
The editor's able to see where
the definitions are, embed the
documentation, and pull
it as needed.
And it turns out that
StoryContentView, reading
around a little bit, is the
one we want to modify.
So let's take a look at that.
So the first complaint we
might have is, well,
StoryContentView, that
was a little bit
hard for me to find.
Gee, it would be nice if I could
change that name so the
next person that has
to dive into it can
find it more easily.
So it turns out that that's
a pretty easy thing
to do here in Dart.
We can just go ahead
and rename it.
And we can call it
ExpandedStoryView.
And the editor's able to do the
right thing here, and just
go ahead and change.
And you could see that this
constructor here magically
changed as well.
And if we go to a terminal--
Dan mentioned grep.
Sometimes we like to do tools
like grep or diff.
And we can see that a number
of changes have been made
throughout the code base,
in this case.
Not too many.
This particular View isn't
accessed very many places.
Let's do something maybe a
little bit more risky.
The item shows up all over the
place in our core code.
So that's a case where you don't
want to just do Search
and Replace, because you'll
probably end up changing a lot
of things you didn't
mean to change.
And again, the Rename
facility here is
actually, it's quite nice.
It's able to just use the
structure and the types to
know what the right
thing to do is.
And let's go ahead and Name
Item Article here.
And you can see it
does that live.
And if we go back and grep
again for "item," there's
still a bunch of
"items" there.
So it did the right thing.
Of course, we should actually
make sure that
it runs still, right?
Because otherwise,
it's no good.
And sure enough,
it still runs.
It does the right thing.
It's able to reason
about the code.
The tools help you out, which
is the goal here.
So again, we said we wanted to
actually make a change here.
So we ran into a few things we
wanted to fix just to make the
code a little bit more
understandable.
Let's take a look.
So the main thing that any View
in this app is doing is
it's rendering.
And it's an abstraction over
HTML, but it's not a huge
abstraction.
Every time we render, we produce
a new HTML element
that goes into the app.
And in this case, it's taking
the contents of that article.
It's doing some scrubbing.
And we showed how to build
the DOM elements
compositionally by code.
Sometimes it's convenient
to use a large template.
And Dart makes that easy with
the string interpolation, it's
a nice feature.
You can take a big string, a
multiline string, and you'll
notice these little dollar-sign
operations where
we can just call in to code and
embed data from the code
right into the string.
So the Feed Title is here.
Let's go in and add the
author of the article.
So even though we're inside of
a string here, the editor is
able to understand the context,
see that there's this
article in Scope, and tell
you what the fields are.
It knows the Type of that.
And I can just see, hey, there's
an Author Field here
and go ahead and use it.
And Save.
And let's reload and see if
it did the right thing.
Oh, this is--
Sorry.
I keep going to Chrome.
I haven't compiled yet.
So I need to go to Dartium,
because I haven't actually
recompiled.
So Dartium gives me the nice
experience of just being able
to reload, because it's
this native support.
And I can see right here that
next to the Feed Title I have
the author.
So everything just worked.
I'm done with my first change.
So our experience with this
has been really positive.
The goals that we set out really
seem to be working.
We have a language here that's
much more toolable, easy for
us to jump in and use.
And we feel that we're on the
right path for a whole
platform that makes it easier
to write large applications.
You can take everything we've
shown here and download it
yourself and play with it.
This is an early version
of the Dart platform.
The interesting starting
point is dartlang.org.
There's a lot to read there.
The language specification
is pretty stable.
It's not quite yet at 1.0.
You can see the API
documentation for Dart:HTML,
the other core libraries.
You can download the latest
versions of the Dart Editor,
Dartium, all our Command
Line Tools.
And there's a mailing list there
that you can join-- it's
very active--
to join the community,
give us feedback.
A lot of changes have been made
just based on feedback
from the community.
It's been great.
All the code, if you want to
build it yourself, or just
look at how it's implemented,
it's all there at
dart.googlecode.com.
That includes Dartium, the
Dart2JS, Compiler, the Virtual
Machine, the Editor, all the
libraries, and Swarm, the
sample app there.
So you can basically look at
all the code you want, muck
with it, tell us what you
learn, play with it.
It's all there.
You can learn a lot more at
Google I/O. If you didn't make
it to Lars' and Kasper's
talk, it's recorded.
So you can find out more about
the Dart language.
It's a great starting point.
In this very room, there'll be
another talk in just a few
minutes on migrating code from
GWT to Dart, where Ray will
talk about that.
And you can learn about
both of those.
And then all afternoon, we
have Dart Office Hours.
So you can find us, ask us
questions, and just get your
hands dirty with some
of the stuff.
If you really want to get your
hands dirty, come to the Code
Lab tomorrow that Seth and
Jamie will be running.
A lot of us will be there.
It's your chance to write
your first Dart app.
DAN GROVE: Yeah,
so summing up.
If you only remember three
things coming out of this
talk, first of all,
remember that the
web has changed hugely.
The last five years have really
delivered a whole lot
of changes in capabilities
and in speed.
Secondly, in order to take
advantage of this, you've got
to be able to program
at scale, and Dart
enables you to do this.
And finally, over the next year,
Dart will enable modern
web apps by providing a large
set of libraries to really
make this a straightforward
procedure.
Thanks, and if you have
questions, the
mic is there, I believe.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: OK.
I wondered, our search engines
were indexing dot application.
Do you have a way to build
static versions to
be crawled by robots?
DAN GROVE: To allow it to
be crawled by robots.
We haven't done anything in
particular on this yet, but
I'm sure we will.
AUDIENCE: So basically when you
write a dot application,
it won't appear in
Google Results.
VIJAY MENON: So we expect
when people deploy Dart
applications that you'll
be able to--
And you can do server-side
detection to check whether the
browser that's hitting your site
has native Dart support
and serve accordingly
Dart or JavaScript.
So I haven't thought
very deeply about
your specific case.
But that should be a case where,
again, you can take
advantage of the fact that this
just runs on all browsers.
DAN GROVE: Yeah, it should be
no different from running a
JavaScript application.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So I realize you're going to
have a talk next about the
transition from GWT to Dart.
But I was wondering if you could
just mention briefly
what the differences
are between the
goals of the two projects?
They seem to have a
lot of overlap.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
So I think there's actually--
So first of all, there's both
the talk today, and then
there's a talk later this week
about the future of GWT.
So we have not actually paid a
ton of attention to GWT on the
Dart project.
We're really trying to build
a whole new platform.
And the goals may be similar.
But we also think that we can
do much better than Java in
terms of the developer
workflow.
VIJAY MENON: If you went to Lars
and Kaspar's talk, you
can see that when they created
the language, it borrowed a
lot of elements from different
languages, including Java.
So Dart really tries to hit the
space between JavaScript
and Java and get a lot of
the best of both worlds.
You get the checking and
toolability from Java but also
some of the terseness and
simplicity from JavaScript.
Ray's going to go into detail
on some side-by-side
comparisons of how the things
really compare.
So I highly recommend that if
you're interested in that, you
stick around for that talk.
AUDIENCE: I was just curious
how the performance of Dart
code running in the VM compares
to V8 optimized
JavaScript.
DAN GROVE: Where's Lars?
I think the answer is that
it's not there yet.
If you looked at the VM today,
it exceeds where Chrome was
when Chrome launched
by a decent amount.
But there is still
a long way to go.
VIJAY MENON: Yeah, I mean
performance is something
that's being actively
worked on.
It's a big theme, so definitely
at release point,
it will get to better than V8.
If you run natively it should
be pretty much close to
hand-optimized code
if you compile.
For us it's nice because it's
already pretty fast.
And it's getting faster
underneath us every day.
So that's pretty cool.
DAN GROVE: Yeah we have the
advantage of working on a
project that has among the best
VM performance people in
the world working on it.
And they're unbelievably driven
to make this faster.
VIJAY MENON: One great thing of
this being very open too,
is that if you complain about
performance on a certain thing
on the mailing list, it tends to
get a lot of attention too.
So the things we care about,
again, performance wasn't so
much of an issue when
we did Swarm.
So we were able to get the
performance we wanted, and we
were able to--
AUDIENCE: Is that a milestone
that you have for like--
I know the Dart release is
coming up in fall 2012.
Is that something you
have in a miles--
DAN GROVE: You know, I don't
know that we've published an
official goal for that,
but I suspect one
will be coming soon.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, guys,
for a great talk.
The question is, obviously,
people have quite a large code
base over existing JavaScript.
Do you consider implementing
any way to call
JavaScript from Dart?
DAN GROVE: That's a
great question.
VIJAY MENON: That's a
fantastic question.
That's something that we're
actually actively
looking at right now.
And we do want to have a good
solution for that in place in
the next few months.
DAN GROVE: In fact, that's
something that you're going to
be working on, I believe.
VIJAY MENON: I think I
signed up for that.
So look for something.
We're looking at a few
different solutions.
If you keep an eye on the
mailing list, you can actually
look at the details of the code
reviews of the different
things that we're playing
around with there.
We're trying to do it in a way
that you get a good experience
when you're running Dart
natively, as well as when
you're compiling Dart
to JavaScript.
And we're trying to make a very
nice interop layer that
performs pretty well.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAN GROVE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is, how does Dart--
All these presentations that I
see, they all compare to the
current version of JavaScript,
whereas the next version,
Harmony, has got a lot of the
same things I'm seeing.
It's got modules, string
interpolation, lexical scoping.
It's got a lot of
things that--
So I'm wondering, I guess, how
does Dart stack up to the next
version of JavaScript?
And are you worried
about adoption?
Is that your biggest
thing, or--
DAN GROVE: Well, we care hugely
about adoption, obviously.
VIJAY MENON: Yeah.
But ultimately, this is about
making web apps great.
And if JavaScript gets
better and better,
that's a good thing.
And it is getting better
and better.
Lars and Kasper can
go into a lot of
detail there where they've--
You can't always
just add to the
language and make it better.
There are challenges,
particularly at the
implementation level, and also
holes in the semantics that
are hard to get around.
So there is an advantage,
at some point--
And JavaScript's been around
for a long time.
There are advantages that we can
get from starting anew and
taking a lot of the lessons
from JavaScript.
You might still be able to get
a lot of what you want coding
in JavaScript.
I think everyone's experience
will vary.
So what we would say is to try
out these different things and
see what works best for you.
DAN GROVE: Yeah, and I think
Lars and Kasper would tell you
that, on a fundamental basis,
you can make Dart
significantly faster
than JavaScript.
They're probably the best
qualified people in the world
to make that statement.
And they're very
clear about it.
AUDIENCE: Right.
And as far as adoption, do you
ever see it landing in Firefox
or other browsers,
the native VM?
DAN GROVE: That is so far away
that we can't even consider it
right now, which is why we
have to have a great
compilation story.
VIJAY MENON: Yeah, Dart2JS is
really the deployment story,
even now for Chrome as well.
And we've got to make that
really, really good.
And Dart's been designed so
it can compile well to
JavaScript.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm curious about debugging.
You showed how you set a
breakpoint in the IDE.
Is this a browser plug-in,
or how does it work?
And does it mean that you
only can debug in
Dartium right now?
I can say a little
bit about that.
So Chrome has support for
external debuggers.
And I don't think we had to--
We had to do the hook-up
for the Dart VM.
But otherwise, you can do
similar things with V8 and
external debuggers.
And there's also the internal
dev tools in Chrome that you
can use as a debugger as well,
with V8 and JavaScript on
regular Chrome, and on
Dartium, that as
well as Dart code.
So really, just using the
existing plumbing that's there
in the browser.
DAN GROVE: Yeah, and the other
approach you can use, of
course, is debugging the
JavaScript code that's
produced by the Compiler, which
is a pretty reasonable
experience.
VIJAY MENON: There's actually
work going on right now in
using Source Maps.
Chrome has Source Maps.
So if you're compiling from any
language to JavaScript,
you can get a better debugging
experience and look at your
original source and see
how that [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: You probably can't
debug in IE or Firefox?
DAN GROVE: You would debug the
generated JavaScript code.
AUDIENCE: All right.
DAN GROVE: And that's a pretty
decent experience.
We have a lot of experience
doing that, and it's not bad.
AUDIENCE: And second question.
You said the IDE is
built on Eclipse.
Is it an Eclipse plug-in,
or is it stand-alone?
VIJAY MENON: It's stand-alone
right now, but
I think Lars actually--
DAN GROVE: I think he answered
this in the last one.
VIJAY MENON: Answered
this question.
So I'll just repeat what
he said, which is
that it will come.
There will be an Eclipse
plug-in.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
VIJAY MENON: Yep.
AUDIENCE: I was curious about
unit test support.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
VIJAY MENON: Yeah, we care
a lot about unit test.
There is a unit test library
that's been in Dart for a
long, long time.
And we use it pretty heavily.
DAN GROVE: Yeah, and there's--
We're always adding new
testing support.
So there's a new mocking
library that's going in
nowadays, for instance.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I wonder about the commitment
that Google has to Dart.
Is it just a playground where
you evaluate what's possible
and what's nice?
Or is Google actually putting
critical applications from
Google [INAUDIBLE]?
DAN GROVE: Dart has started
being used inside Google to
build critical applications
at this point.
I would tell you, in terms of
commitment, I'm pretty committed.
VIJAY MENON: Yeah.
DAN GROVE: We have a very large
team, and we're spending
a huge number of resources
to make Dart successful.
VIJAY MENON: And we're working
pretty closely with those
teams to make it a success.
DAN GROVE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Do you have time for
one more fast question?
Is there any plans like to
support or maybe solely be
supported--
Can I run my Dart apps like
stand-alone on any V8
implementation outside of the
browser, just throwing away
the HTML part with
DOM and stuff.
VIJAY MENON: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Yeah like,
I mean, basically,
will it run on nojs?
Like if I just compile
and run it?
VIJAY MENON: So nojs has been
a big source of inspiration.
And I think as Kasper mentioned
in the last talk,
the Compiler is self-hosting
as well, right?
And it's a standalone app
written in Dart that reads
from the file system using
server-side APIs that we don't
make available in the browser.
That is part of the long-term
version of Dart, to actually
have code that you can share.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but basically
the standard API should work,
[INAUDIBLE].
VIJAY MENON: Yeah, the core
libraries will work
everywhere.
We want to make that--
We want to make it as easy as
possible to take code from the
server and put it in the
client, and vice versa.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, guys.
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
In one of your demos you did a
query of Canvas elements, put
them into a non-generified
list, and then iterated
through those and was able to
context-assist out the 2D context.
VIJAY MENON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How did you do that?
VIJAY MENON: That's
really cool.
Actually, I only discovered
that this week.
Like I said, the great thing
about having this active team
is that stuff just improves
under the hood.
And that was a new feature that
just started working, I
think, in the last week.
So the Dart Editor is
smart enough to do a
class hierarchy analysis.
It essentially knows the base
type of what you've got.
And it's able to look at the
sub-types and give you a list
of all the possibilities that
you could want to do.
Now if I had put list bracket
Canvas element, I would have
gotten a shorter list of
completion, potentially, when
I pulled stuff out.
So it can still be sort
of advantageous.
And we're still trying to figure
out what the right
balance of that is.
Being able to put that type
information is useful, because
we do-- and I didn't show
an example of this.
But you do have the opportunity
to validate that
at run time and get some
early error checking.
You can kind of think of it
as assertions in the code.
But yeah, the tooling is able to
actually reason a lot about
the code because it knows
the structure.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So it grabbed all of the
attributes of anything that
extended, element or whatever.
And--
VIJAY MENON: Yeah, so if it
knows that the base type is
element, it's able
to show you--
I don't know if this showed up
this time, but if I start
typing "context," I can see the
context field that's on
the audio element as well as the
context 2D that's on the
Canvas element.
And if I put the more specific
type in there, I would see a
more filtered list.
AUDIENCE: And I assume if you
were to put an attribute that
didn't exist, you'd
get some type of
runtime error or something?
VIJAY MENON: If you put
an attribute that
doesn't exist, the--
DAN GROVE: Yeah, you'll actually
get a runtime--
It's a run--
VIJAY MENON: First of all, if it
can tell it statically, it
will tell you a warning
right there.
DAN GROVE: But it'll still
let you compile it.
VIJAY MENON: It would still
But the more common case is that
you actually try to get
the context 2D, but you have an
audio element or a div or
something like that, right.
And there, you will
fail at runtime.
And you will get an error,
an exception.
And if you're running in the
debugger, it will stop right
there at the point at which
it made that call.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: When will I be able to
deploy my server-side Dart
code to Google App Engine?
DAN GROVE: I don't know.
We haven't made any announcement
about that yet.
VIJAY MENON: Good question,
though.
DAN GROVE: It's a
good question.
OK, so I guess that's it.
VIJAY MENON: Thanks
for coming.
DAN GROVE: Thanks.